PROFESSOR: So we come now to
the topic of induction, which
is a standard part of a
high school curriculum
and you've probably seen
before, but is nevertheless
worth looking at at
the level that we
look at things in this class.
So the idea of induction
can be-- one way
to explain it is this way.
Suppose that I plan
to be assigning colors
to the non-negative integers
like, say, in this example,
I color zero blue and one red
and two blue and three red
and four and five green,
and it goes on somehow.
OK.
Now I'm going to describe to you
a coloring that I have in mind,
and we'll see whether you
can figure out what it is.
Here are the properties
that my coloring has.
First of all, I've
colored zero red,
and I've also
continued the coloring
satisfying the following rule.
If I have an integer that's
next to a red integer,
then it's red also.
Any integer next to a
red integer is red also.
So what's my coloring?
Well, you obviously realize
that they're all red.
They have to be.
And there they are.
OK.
This is actually a statement.
It can be read as a statement
of the rule of induction.
It's kind of a self-evident
axiom about numbers,
but let's state it abstractly.
So first of all, what
induction is assuming
is that you have some
property of numbers.
Call it red, R. And R
of zero you're told,
and you're also told that
R of zero implies R of 1,
and that R of 1 implies R of
2, and R of 2 implies R of 3,
and in general R of n implies
R of n plus 1, and so on.
So we've written it out
this way as an infinite set
of implications to
emphasize that that's
what the rule that I stated,
that if an integer is
next to a red integer then
it's red, is shorthand for.
It's really a shorthand
for this infinite number
of different implications,
each of which
has to hold in order for
you to be able to apply
the rule of induction.
Well, what can you conclude
if all of these things hold?
Well, then you can conclude
that zero is red and one is red
and two is red and
n is red, and so on.
OK.
Now of course, there's
a much more concise way
to express both these
antecedents above the line
and the conclusion below
the line using quantifiers,
namely the antecedents
could simply
be said by two predicate
formulas, R of 0,
comma, for all n, R of
n implies R of n plus 1.
That's really a summary of what
we said on the first slide,
that if an integer is less than
a red integer, then it's red.
That is, n plus 1 is next to n.
If n is red, then
n plus 1 is red.
Similarly, the stuff below the
line, that R of zero, R of one
and so on hold is simply
expressed as for all m, R of m
holds.
And this is the form
of the induction rule.
It's read that if
you've proved R of 0
and you've proved that,
for every n, R of n
implies R of n plus 1, then you
can conclude that for every m,
R of m holds, where the
variables are all ranging
over the non-negative integers.
By the way, notice that I
used n for the variable name
above the line in
the antecedent,
and m for the variable line
below in the consequent.
I can use any names that I
like for bound variables,
just as in when you define
a procedure you can name
the parameters of the
procedure anything you like,
because they're local variables.
And I've used an m in the
bottom and an n in the top just
to emphasize that those
variables have nothing
to do with each other, which is
a point that sometimes confuses
students.
OK.
Sometimes the rule
of induction is
explained in terms of dominoes.
You have all these dominoes
lined up next to each other.
You knock one over, it knocks
over the next one, and so on.
If that helps you think
about and remember dominoes,
that's fine.
OK.
Let's apply
induction-- maybe one
of the most basic and
standard applications
would be to prove a
numerical identity.
So let's prove one that
we've actually seen before.
This is the formula
that we've previously
proved using the
well-ordering principle
for the sum of a geometric--
for a geometric sum.
The sum of R to the 0, R
to the 1, up to R to the n.
And the claim is that
that's equal to R
to the n plus 1 minus
1 divided by R minus 1.
So this sum of n
plus 1 terms actually
can be expressed concisely
with a fairly single--
a single, simple term.
Of course, this only
works if R is not 1,
because I can't have
the denominator be zero.
All right.
How do we prove it?
Well, I'm going to do the proof.
And at the same time
that I do the proof,
I'm going to show you kind
of a standard template
that you can pull out and
use for induction proofs.
So the template, it's just
an organizational method
to do the proof.
I'm doing the
template in magenta.
So that's the part that
really is form, not substance.
There's no math in it,
it's just the structure
that we're going to
organize the proofs in,
at least in the beginning.
So here we go.
The first thing you
do is tell your reader
that you're going to be
using proof by induction.
That helps them
understand what's coming.
So you begin with the line
proof by induction on n.
Now n is not in magenta
because sometimes you
use different variables,
and sometimes there'll
be many variables
in the assertion.
So you need to tell
the reader just which
one is the one that you're going
to be applying induction to.
All right.
That said, the most
important part of the proof,
the part where there's
usually a mistake-- if there's
a mistake anywhere, it's usually
in the absence of the statement
of an induction hypothesis, or a
misguided induction hypothesis.
So the next part of
the template says
the induction hypothesis P
of n is-- and in this case,
our induction hypothesis is
that this equality holds.
That's what we're
trying to prove.
So the induction
hypothesis is P of n.
The objective, then, implicitly,
when we're doing induction
with this induction hypothesis,
is to prove that for all n,
P of n calls.
This identity works for all
non-negative integers n.
OK.
Having stated the
induction hypothesis,
the first thing we have to
do is work on the base case.
That is, prove it
for n equals 0.
Now we're telling the
reader that it's n equals
0 because sometimes it's
convenient to start at n
equals 1 or n equals
2, and then you're
just concluding that
the property holds
for all n greater
than or equal to 1,
or however-- all n
greater than or equal
to wherever you started.
So we're going to start at 0,
which is the standard place.
And what do we have to check?
We have to check that
the sum on the left,
when n goes to-- when n is
0, is equal to the sum--
to the formula on the
right when n is 0.
Well the sum on the
left, when n is 0,
it's really just 1, because
it's going from R to the 0
to R to the 0.
The R and the R squared,
they're a little misleading
because they're not
really there when n is 0.
So the left-hand side is
one, and the right-hand side
is R minus 1 over R minus 1,
which is 1 since R is not 1.
So sure enough, it
checks, and we're OK.
The case n equals 0
has now been proved.
So the next thing we have
to do in the template
is to go to the inductive step.
And that's where we
assume that P of n holds.
And we're allowed to use
the P of n assumption
in order to prove that
P of n plus 1 holds,
where the only thing
that we know about n
besides that P of
n holds is that n
is greater than or equal to 0.
And our proof has to work
for all possible n that
are greater than or equal to 0.
All right.
Well, now we can start doing
the non-template method that
has to do with the content
of what we're actually
trying to prove.
This is what I want to prove.
This is P of n plus 1.
It's gotten by replacing the n's
in the previous equation by n
plus 1's.
I'd like to have that be.
OK.
How do I get to that?
Well, I can assume P of n, which
kind of looks like it already.
It's a good head start to
getting to P of n plus 1.
So I'm allowed to assume that
this equality holds for n.
I don't know what n
is except that it's
a non-negative integer, but
this equality holds for n.
And I have to prove that
it holds for n plus 1.
Well, if you look at this,
what I'm trying to prove
is something about the sum that
goes up to R to the n plus 1.
So given this equation, I
can turn the left-hand side
into the sum that
I'm interested in.
That is, the sum of powers of R
up to the n plus 1st power of R
simply by adding
R to the n plus 1
to both sides, an
obvious strategic move,
or tactical move.
OK.
So doing that, I
get this equality,
which I've now proved from
the induction hypothesis.
Namely, the sum up
to R to the n plus 1,
which is what I'm
interested in, is
equal to this
algebraic expression
on the right-hand side.
And if I'm lucky, and
of course I will be,
the right-hand side
is going to simplify
to be the target expression,
with n replaced by n plus 1.
So what happens is--
let's put R to the n
plus 1 over this common
denominator, R minus 1.
And I get the second
term, and then
you can do a little bit of
algebraic simplification,
trivial, and you'll realize
that, sure enough, it
simplifies to R to the n
plus 1 plus 1 minus 1 over R
minus 1, which was exactly
the equality that I
was hoping to prove.
So in fact, at this
point we can say
that we've proved P
of n plus 1, and we've
completed the induction proof.
We're done.
OK.
That is the first basic
example of an induction proof.
And the whole template
is now visible,
except maybe there should have
been a QED or a Done statement.
All right.
By the way, as an aside, and
we already saw a little problem
with this, the three dots
that appeared in the sum
are called an ellipsis.
Plural is ellipses.
And they're used
where the writer
is trying to tell the
reader that there's
an obvious pattern that the
reader is expected to see,
which I think is fairly
clear in this case.
You go-- you know, it's R to
the 0, R to the 1, R to the 2,
R to the 3, up to R to the n.
The difficulty is that
sometimes the ellipsis
can cause some confusion.
For example, we had to
figure out that when n is 0,
the left-hand side
actually just meant 1.
It was just R to the
0, so the R and the R
squared weren't really there.
One way to really avoid
that kind of fence post
problem where you've shown--
in order to make clear
what the pattern is, you've
shown more than it may-- more
of a pattern than
may always be there--
is to use a precise mathematical
notation where I actually
tell you the pattern
of the i-th term,
and tell you that you should
sum from i equals 0 to n.
So the sigma notation
is shorthand for sum,
and I'm telling you that
the i-th term in the sum
is R to the i, and it's going
to run from i equals 0 to n.
So this is a sort of
mathematical notation
for a for loop or a do loop--
do from i equals 0 to n,
add R to the i plus R to
the i to the accumulator.
And the sum notation is
certainly more precise.
But sometimes, it's
actually harder
to read than simply
showing you the pattern,
because the pattern often
is visible visually.
OK, now let me tell
you a little story.
And it's a made-up story,
but it's kind of fun to tell.
This is the familiar
building, the Stata Center.
And this is actually
a design mock-up
that the architects produced
for the MIT team that
was overseeing the construction
and design of the building
to show what the student
lobby would look like,
the student street.
Now the story goes that part of
the plan for the student street
was to have a plaza
that was going
to be built out of
unit size squares,
but an uncertain number of them.
There was going to be a
parameter that determined
the size of the square.
And the size of the
square was actually
going to be a power of two
by a power of two made out
of unit size tiles.
So there would be
2 to the n times 2
to the n unit size tiles
filling up this square plaza.
And the plaza was to be
tiled with these unit tiles,
but one tile space
was to be left blank
so that the statue
of a-- what was then
the potential donor,
Bill, could be placed
in the middle as an
incentive for him
to donate funds for the
completion of the building,
which indeed he did.
So the puzzle, then,
was put forward
by the architect
Frank Gehry, who
many regard, after
Frank Lloyd Wright,
as the greatest architect
of the 20th century.
Gehry specified for
aesthetic reasons
that he wanted to
the square to be
tiled with L-shaped
tiles that were made out
of three unit squares.
He thought that that would
give a pretty design,
and it actually does.
So here's an example of
tiling the n equals 3 case,
[? 2 ?] [? to the-- ?] [? 2 ?]
[? cubed ?] equals 8x8 plaza
with Bill in the middle.
There is the 8x8 plaza tiled
with these L-shaped tiles, each
consisting of three unit tiles.
So the question was that
the exact size of the square
was to be determined by other
architectural considerations.
So it was parametrized by n,
which is going to be 2 to the n
by 2 to the n.
The question was, can you always
find such a tiling no matter
how big the square is and
leave Bill in the middle.
Well, let's try to
prove it by induction.
The induction
hypothesis-- we're trying
to prove a theorem that, for any
2 to the n by 2 to the n plaza,
we can make Bill
and Frank happy.
That is, Bill's happy
when he's in the middle,
and Frank is happy when
the rest of the square
is covered with L-shaped tiles.
By the way, middle is
a little bit ambiguous
because there are really
four middle squares.
But of course, it
doesn't matter which one
you fill, because if you
wanted a different one
you could just rotate
the whole square
and get any one of the
four middle squares
empty for the Bill statue.
So an induction proof
would proceed by induction
on something or other.
And the obvious
thing is the n that's
in the statement of the theorem.
And the induction hypothesis
would straightforwardly
be that we can
tile to 2 to the n
by 2 to the n plaza
with Bill in the middle.
OK.
The base case is n equals 0.
That's a 2 to the
1 by 2 to the 2.
It's a 1x1 square.
OK, well, not a problem.
You just put Bill
in the one square,
and you tile the rest
with no L-shaped tiles.
That fits the rules.
The base case n equals
1-- n equals 0 is covered.
All right.
So now we come to the
double size square,
the square that's of
size 2 to the n plus 1
by 2 to the n plus 1.
I have to tile that
with Bill in the middle,
but I have a fairly
powerful induction
hypothesis that I'm
allowed to assume, namely
that I can tile the half
size square, the 2 to the n
by 2 to the n square, and
get Bill in the middle.
So obviously, the
double size square
is made out of four
half-sized squares.
And so I can try to fill
up the whole square that's
2 to the-- the whole full-sized
square, or double-sized square,
2 to the n plus 1 by
2 to the n plus 1,
by working with my ability to
tile them with L-shaped tiles,
leaving Bill in the middle for
each of those four subsquares.
So I can assume that,
and now I'm stuck really.
What do I do?
How do I use this ability to
put Bill in the middle of each
of those four quadrants
in order to color--
to fill in the whole
thing with N-shaped tiles?
I'm stuck.
And the point of this
example is to show you
the way to get unstuck,
which is kind of unexpected.
I'm actually going
to get unstuck
by proving something stronger.
I'm actually going to prove
that we can find a tiling using
L-shaped squares with Bill
placed in any specified square
that you like.
Wherever you want
to put him, I can
tile the rest with
L-shaped tiles
and leave the specified
single square blank for Bill
to be inserted, for a statue
of Bill to be put there.
So what's unintuitive
about this is that I'm
proving something stronger.
It ought to be harder
to prove, right?
But because I'm trying to prove
a conclusion that's stronger,
I also have a stronger
induction hypothesis
to work with in
conducting the proof.
And the net proof
actually, as you'll see,
is going to be easier.
So let's do it with the
stronger induction hypothesis.
The theorem is, again, for any
2 to the n by 2 to the n plaza,
so we can make Bill
and Frank happy.
Prove by induction on n.
But with a revised
induction hypothesis--
I'm calling it P
of n again-- which
is I can tile the square
with Bill anywhere.
So the base case, n equals
0, is the same as before.
It's just 1x1.
So I put Bill in the
only tile that there
is, which is both the middle and
the corner and everything else.
And the base case
doesn't change.
For the inductive step, now
I have a more powerful thing
that I can assume is the
induction hypothesis.
I can assume that, in any
given square of a 2 to the n
by 2 to the n-- any given tile
location, unit square, of a 2
to the n by 2 to
the n plaza, I can
tile the rest with
L-shaped squares
and get Bill where
I wanted him to be.
And I have to use
that hypothesis
to show that I can get Bill
anywhere that's required in a 2
to the n plus 1 by 2
to the n plus 1 square.
So suppose that we want to
tile Bill in that designated
arbitrary square of the 2 to
the n plus 1 by 2 to the n
plus 1 plaza where we
happen to choose a location
where Bill is in the
upper right quadrant,
in the upper right
half size square.
All right.
So my hypothesis, I can
fill in the purple square,
that quadrant, with
L-shaped tiles,
leaving Bill in the place
that he's supposed to be.
Well, here's the trick.
With the other three, since
I can tile them with Bill
anywhere, I'm going
to tile them with Bill
in the respective corners of
those three other subsquares,
which meet in the center of the
full-size plaza, as shown here.
And having done that,
now it's obvious
how to fill up the
whole 2 to the n plus 1
by 2 to the n plus 1 plaza,
because I pull those four
separate pieces together to form
the full-size 2 to the n plus 1
by 2 to the n plus 1 plaza.
And look, I just put an
L-shaped tile in the middle
to fill up those three
corner Bills, and I'm done.
And the proof is complete.
We have just proved by
induction that indeed you
can tile any power of 2 by power
of 2 square putting-- leaving
Bill wherever you want
him, and the rest filled
with L-shaped tiles.
Now notice that a
part of this process
actually is implicitly
defining a recursive procedure
to actually do the tiling.
If you watch the
way the proof went,
if I was going to write a
recursive procedure to do
the tiling, what I
would do is say OK,
you give me input
n plus 1, which
are the dimensions-- the
specification of the dimensions
of the plaza, input
n plus 1-- or input n
means it's 2 the
n by 2 to the n.
How do I do that?
Well, you tell me
where you want Bill
to be as another
parameter, and then I
will call myself recursively
on four half size squares.
So that is, call
myself to do squares
with dimension parameter n minus
1 four times for each quadrant,
each time specifying
in those quarters
where I want Bill to be.
The recursive procedure will
return an L-shaped tiling
of those four pieces, and then
I take those, fit them together,
tile that middle, and
I wind up with a tiling
of the whole region.
So what I've just
talked through is
the description of a very easily
written recursive procedure
that would print out a picture
of an L-shaped tiling given,
as input, any number n.
And that's, in fact, that
how we got the 8x8 tiling,
although we did it by hand
rather than writing a program.
And that's enough
of two examples
of basic mathematical induction.